atari a marqué les jeux vidéo dans les
années 80 et tente maintenant une percée
dans le secteur hôtelier
après la console voici l'hôtel atari
l'entreprise prévoit ouvrir lé 8
établissements aux états unis avec un
premier hôtel qui ouvrira ses portes à
phoenix en arizona
dès cette année chicago las vegas san
francisco et seattle sont aussi dans la
mire du groupe
mais attention l'entreprise ne se dit-on
pop complètement des jeux vidéo qui ont
fait sa renommée
l'idée c'est de proposer un concept
hôtelier attrayant pour les joueurs avec
les espaces dédiés aux jeux vidéo
la réalité virtuelle et augmentée le
radis arcade des bars également où
seront diffusés des compétitions de
sport électronique
après une faillite retentissante
atteindre naîtra aussi avec une nouvelle
console la bcs qui est attendu au
printemps
[Musique]